America has celebrated Memorial Day for
at least 150 years it's a post-civil war
holiday that used to be called
decoration day the name morphed over
time as the holiday grew post-world War
one to commemorate all who have died in
service to the country remembering our
fallen soldiers is more than nostalgia
it's about we engaging with the
principles that define America because
Memorial Day renews the memory of those
who gave their lives that this nation
might live
it reminds us that our nation is
dedicated to liberty and equality our
national cemeteries at Arlington and
elsewhere make it a point to specify the
individual names of fallen soldiers on
those rows on rows of headstones to
recognize the equal worthiness of each
of its dead soldiers to be remembered by
name not all democracies have done this
nation Athens dead soldiers were
nameless because it was only the city of
Athens that was meant to be remembered
it matters how a government thinks of
and treats its military dead because it
reveals how it thinks about citizens and
government do you think Americans have
lost sight of the meaning of Memorial
Day let us know in your comments also
let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds and
be sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI